[Music]
the razer crest is still in one piece in
this scene yes i'm sending the show
because it will eventually blow up this
beautiful beast and i know you feel that
pain too commando is that you under that
bucket ah sudden bobby elvis also what a
weird way to address someone who in
theory you've only ever seen while they
were wearing said bucket unless of
course there's one more person amanda
has unsheathed himself in front of in
which case he really should think about
amending his oath to this is the way
when it's convenient to me you know the
policy
no questions this seems like an
extremely broad and frankly unrealistic
policy let's see how long it lasts
[Music]
so what's the job
eight seconds
the ship wasn't part of the deal now the
crest is the only reason i let you back
in here hey what happened to and you
you will come back here anytime goodness
i know we're dealing with criminals here
but is an ounce of consistency too much
to ask for people
what's the look asking someone who's
wearing a full face helmet about the
look they're giving them billboards not
the first person that would pop in most
people's heads is the badass
sharpshooter on a heist team however i'm
glad he was on the minds of the mando
team because he's great in this role
former imperial sharpshooter
that's not saying much
i wasn't a stormtrooper wise ass wait so
it's known in universe that
stormtroopers candid the broadside of a
bantha and yet they're still being used
i can't believe that thing can fly it's
like a canto bite slot machine how does
that look anything like a slot machine
hello
one member of the team is a woman who
has a long history with the protagonist
cliche this is shiny
invading a mandalorian's personal space
and touching their armor with your blade
without explicit consent you're gonna be
okay sweetheart calling someone you're
not in a relationship with sweetheart
tiny
nice insult pet cemetery two's clancy
brown excited to see what else you might
have up your sleeve later although if
you pull off a good your mom i'll
forgive the tiny
reference fuel navigation
hyperdrive excitement your man wasn't
taken by a rival syndicate he was
arrested
a job is a job yes and eating legos is
eating legos repeating things doesn't
make them a good idea i'm not looking
for that kind of heat but you had no
issue parking your ride on a station
with a former criminal colleague if we
immediately bank into this kind of
attitude
we should be right in that blind spot
this thing is brand new top of the line
and not to mention [ __ ] huge but
still has an enemy ship has an easily
exploitable blind spot cliche built
right in who is building these things
kids also this compartment filled with
weapons isn't locked it's really a
no-brainer when there's a band of
untrustworthy ruthless mercenaries on
board apparently they're the greatest
warriors in the galaxy and why are they
all dead burke would be darth revan at
tv sins he never takes off the helmet
this is the way
blasphemy
this compartment filled with baby yoda
isn't locked surely a no-brainer when
there's a band of untrustworthy you get
the idea it's impressive that this
gunship has survived the empire this
episode is 17 characters talking [ __ ]
about mando's ship is zeon specialty
really just knives i mean this would be
of questionable value versus an organic
crew with guns but it's downright
idiotic against an entirely metal crew
with guns
[Music]
why is berg even here i don't care if
he's the muscle if he isn't smart enough
to realize that prematurely pew-pewing a
harmless droid that's likely linked to
the deadly droids isn't a good idea then
i'd happily carry the damn heavy things
myself how is the backpack blaster
activated how does it know what to aim
for or when to fire when will i stop
trying to make sense of any of the tech
in star wars not today get that blaster
out of my face mando this mandalorian
standoffs for some time sure berg's got
big muscles but any droid that can be
taken down this easily by discount
hellboy here really has no place being
assigned to a maximum security ship
but why
what are they gaining from throwing
mando in the prison vengeance there's no
profit in vengeance surely they know
their odds are significantly improved if
he's still with them fortunately for
mando this arm still works despite being
disconnected from its power source and
the ai that controls it i can't tell if
these are the computer graphics being
displayed on the ship's computer or if
xero is in the middle of a game of tron
deadly discs on his in television
it seems comms are no longer functioning
calms go down in the middle of a
dangerous mission cliche and yeah maybe
i've laid on the cliche sins a little
thick but that's only because this
episode is as well whatever ran promised
i'll see to it you get triple share you
better be good for it
i mean i'd probably take that laugh to
mean something like what do you think
[ __ ] you just broke me out of prison
and all i have is this vest and a pair
of lovely head calves of course i'm not
good for it but you trust who you want
to trust mayfeld
polo berg survives this
these look like the same droids from
earlier so why are they going down so
much easier this time around for those
previous droids on special roids to help
avoid the weapons being deployed or am i
doomed to be an annoyed humanoid
screaming in to avoid devoid of joyed i
mean joy
okay when did this turn into james wands
the mandalorian i did the job
yeah you did so ranzar was essentially
full of [ __ ] when he said that it's a
five-person job right because it quickly
became abundantly apparent that this was
in fact a one
maybe two person gig including the robot
mando does the vast majority of the
droid control while the others seem to
be actively sabotaging the mission at
every opportunity not only does mando
retrieve the prisoner alone but he does
it while facing three additional
opponents that weren't even in the
original brief kill him why kill him
after he's taken your money it's not
like he's any less dangerous inside the
spaceship with lasers
um
guys if the tracking beacon was
activated as a distress call isn't it at
least possible that it's still being
held by the poor bastard that sent the
message yes i know we were told earlier
that this beacon would result in
immediate destruction but when did shoot
first and rescue the charred remains of
the dead hostages later become the
republic's standing orders
you know the policy
no questions so what's the job this is
the guy what did he get out of it you
remember what you said amanda we did
some crazy stuff didn't we don't take
long does it why are we using this one
why are they all dead as good as they
say he never takes off the helmet i
never seen his face what is that you get
lonely up here buddy did you two make
that what is it like a pet or something
is that true amanda we always paranoid
you didn't think we need to know that
tiny little detail are you questioning
my managerial style shion do you have a
name is it not your code aren't you a
man of honor or the others no questions
asked that's the policy right
houston we have a problem
don't mess with the bull young man
you'll get the horns
it's off
that means i turn it on
and just walk away
let's all see you right
where we're going
we won't need eyes to say
i'll try again
this little fella
i said
put the bunny
back in the box
stop or i'll say stop again
what's your name i'm batman
you were hired to do a job right better
alive you're coming with me